quand les choses s'emballent il faut
peut-être se mettre en situation de
réguler ou de couper les réseaux sociaux
c'est l'urgence qu'à souligner Emmanuel
Macron devant les maires de France le 30
juin dernier alors que le pays était
submergé par des violences sans
précédent mais le gouvernement a-t-il
vraiment la possibilité de restreindre
ou couper l'accès au réseau sociaux en
cas d'épisode violent l'exécutif est
formel Twitter snapchat Tik Tok
Instagram les plateformes les plus
populaires parmi les jeunes ont joué un
rôle crucial dans l'escalade des
violences liés à la mort de Naël à
partir du 27 juin techniquement c'est
tout à fait faisable c'est ce que nous
explique Jean Cattan secrétaire général
du Conseil National du Numérique cela
fait longtemps que les tabloc décide
problématiques comme ceux de jeux en
ligne ou de propagande terroristes par
exemple pour faire cela l'administration
peut s'attaquer au système de non de
domaine qui est utilisé par les
fournisseurs d'accès à Internet les
internautes ont alors plus accès aux
pages web en question et cette pratique
peut facilement s'étendre aux
applications comme c'est le cas en Iran
en Turquie ou en Russie mais elle se
heurte à un obstacle juridique la mesure
de en effet de valider au préalable par
le juge judiciaire qui en apprécie alors
la la personnalité en 2020 la loi avia
qui exigeait des réseaux sociaux de
retirer sous 24 heures les contenus
haineux avaient été rejetés par le
Conseil constitutionnel au motif qu'elle
constituait une atteinte à l'exercice de
la liberté d'expression qui n'est pas
nécessaire ni proportionnée pour autant
la France n'est pas totalement démunie
face à la viralité des contenus violents
sur les réseaux l'Union européenne vient
d'adopter le digital service Act qui
entre en vigueur le 25 août prochain et
vise à atténuer les risques systémiques
des grandes plateformes concrètement ces
dernières devront analyser les risques
qu'elles génèrent et prendre des mesures
appropriées pour lutter contre par
exemple bannir les émoji rieur des
publications violentes ou empêcher
qu'elle soit likées à partir du 25 août
lorsqu'il y aura des contenus haineux
les plateformes auront l'obligation dans
l'instant de les effacer si elle ne le
font pas elles seront immédiatement
sanctionnées le gouvernement français
aura bel et bien la possibilité de
demander une restriction d'accès aux
plateformes en cas d'infraction mais
uniquement en dernier recours et dans le
cadre strict défini par le DSA certains
observateurs mettent toutefois en garde
contre la tentation de l'exécutif de
s'en prendre aux réseaux sociaux et non
aux causes profondes de la violence qui
agite l'Hexagone le problème ce ne sont
pas les réseaux sociaux mais plutôt la
volonté d'une certaine classe politique
de nier le réel vous pouvez bloquer les
réseaux sociaux ça ne changera
absolument rien on préfère tirer sur le
messager que pointer ses propres
responsabilités à savoir l'impuissance
de l'État dans une multitude de domaines
[Musique]